[Music]
if you love zombies and creepy mutated
monsters then keep on watching we are
here with the 20 biggest monsters from
the franchise of Resident Evil which
will include the movies and games in
this universe there is the umbrella
corporation and quite a few others
there are into bioweapons and genetic
research and from these works came the
different viruses that are capable of
transforming and mutating animals and
human bodies into grotesque abominations
so many of these and lists have no
official stated sizes but we have taken
the liberty of estimating them so here
are 20 of the biggest of these Resident
Evil abominations number 20 the astana
the first on the list comes the dreaded
Astana appearing in the game rest in
evil six this mutated monster has a
height of eight to nine feet tall
or 2.4 to 2.7 meters it is considered to
be the most intelligent and resilient
bio weapon ever produced its names
derived from the Serbian word for
revolution the Austin op is a tall
muscular creature with extremely pale
skin and few remnants of long wispy
white blond hair its body is covered
with deep gashes and there is evidence
of surgical enhancements number 19 the
Ouroboros Tyron seen in Resident Evil 2
and one of the first known creations of
the group called nemesis the Ouroboros
tyrant or UT is also referred to as just
a tyrant infected with a new uroboros
virus in combat the UT is a powerful
weapon far faster and stronger than any
other tyrant and can run along walls or
jump up to three stories high the UT can
punch through reinforced steel like
nothing and easily crush cars with
single blows the UT is around 10 to 12
feet tall or 3 to 3.6 meters number 18
Alex Wesker seen in Resident Evil
Revelations 2 Alex Wesker is the primary
antagonist of the game she was a former
researcher for the Umbrella Corporation
and knowing that she wouldn't be able to
escape her imminent death and that
biological immortality could not be
obtained by viruses or human experiments
Alex transferred a digitized copy of her
human consciousness into another house
she then committed suicide but the tea
phobos virus mutated her into a deformed
creature that was around ten to twelve
feet tall
number 17 the super Tyron this super
tyrant form unlike previous tyrants
lacked a clearly exposed heart in
addition unlike previous tyrants they
only produce one moderately mutated claw
arm as opposed to two giant ones even in
the normal form they were easily capable
of killing liqueurs with their colossal
boots and putting them into near-instant
deaths the liquors on the other hand
failed to make any significant damage or
injuries on them despite the numbers
this type of tyrant was a largest
standing at 14 feet tall and seen in
resident evil damnation number 16 the
plan 42 seen in Resident Evil remastered
this was a large plan infused with D
virus and was originally part of the
experiment on botanic subjects by
umbrella researcher dr. Henry satin the
name location that the plan was growing
on was point 42 and hence its name able
to manipulate door knobs and move it
vines plan for the two captured and
drained several researchers of their
blood and when it tried to destroy it
although it was confusing at first since
it was hanging from interior of a
two-story house it was easily 20 feet or
6 meters long by our estimates
number 15 the end s ooh the end s who is
a humanoid creature that is two stories
tall
it's dirty gray skin it's covered in
scars it has filthy gray beards it wears
white cuffs on its four arms and four
legs and John shorts
held up by a belt of rope a gigantic
humanoid bio-organic weapon that appears
in Resident Evil 5 this brutish creature
was created by the pharmaceutical
corporation dry-cell
and deployed in the small African nation
of key juju this creature from Resident
Evil 5 is as said just now thought to be
2 stories tall which would put him
between 20 and 25 feet tall or between 6
to 7.5 meters number 14 El Gigante
this troll-like creature was created by
the los illuminators cult using a human
subject infected with a las Plagas
parasite though the method in which the
subject size was increased is unknown
unlike the Ganados El Gigante has no
powers of reasoning and minimal
intelligence exhibiting savage
animalistic behavior giganta's are
difficult to handle
so only four were created and all of
them were two stories tall or the same
width and s ooh at 20 to 25 feet or six
to 7.5 meters number 13 the big G in
resident to remake William Birkin as he
lay dying used the loss of his strength
to remove a syringe filled with a G
virus and injected himself with it
the virus saved his life as it rapidly
heal its wounds but mutated him into a
savage violent creature this creature
later became bigger and bigger until it
was in the form of enough morphus
monster with many parts and one big eye
in his mouth you it can be estimated to
be 20 to 30 feet long or between 6 to 9
meters number-12 the Kip APO the only
entry from movies from the Resident Evil
final chapter the Kip appeal is a multi
winged behemoth that came from an
undisclosed t-virus mutation the Kiba
Theo's were very large and the sizes are
on the same size of a truck or larger
instead being used for combat they can
be anywhere between 25 and 30 feet or
7.5 to 9 metres long and with a wingspan
of equal size or even bigger number 11
the grave digger this enormous
underground worm with four mandibles in
its ferocious mouth is a ferocious
monster that can kill anyone very
quickly if they are not fast enough to
dodge his attacks or too fat to run away
it is capable of burrowing through the
streets of Raccoon City at tremendous
speed
this gigantic mutant worm is still one
of the most iconic creatures from the
franchise the grave digger is a colossal
worm-like creature with rows of sharp
teeth filling its gaping maw it can
reach up to 30 feet long or nine meters
and they are seen in resident evil 3
number 10 the ogre oh man this entry is
from Resident Evil 6 and called an okra
man and was a series of bio-organic
weapons derivated from the C virus the
name stems from Agra man a Serbian word
synonymous with enormous and gigantic
the creature is an approximately 30 feet
tall humanoid albeit one with very long
arms and an overdeveloped bone structure
as seen in its legs hips and jaw in at
least one instance there is a large rock
mag device that connects to its internal
organs and protrude slightly from its
back the augur man possesses
impressive strength capable of picking
up humans buses and other heavy objects
number nine the Queen leech seen in
resident evil zero Queen leech was
engineered as dr. James Marcus's
greatest achievement and it's biology
differ radically from that of other
natural leeches like other leeches Queen
leech was a hermaphrodite although
unlike other national leeches it was
capable of self fertilization Queen
leech was able to shape its whole body
to mimic that of dr. Marcus becoming
shorter and gaining arms and legs
although its basic form was big around
30 to 35 feet long or 9 to 11 point five
meters and has a number of tentacles
coming out from its body number eight
yann seen in resident evil remastered
this was a bio organic weapon test
subject created at the a CLIA laboratory
it was named yawn due to the way it
opens its mouth before attacking which
resembles our young an adder snake was
taken inside as a research specimen and
infected with an unidentified strain of
T virus this later became the yawn and
grew to a considerable size around 40
feet or 12 meters long and hormonal e
unstable became too aggressive to
control the size of Yuans mouth and its
esophagus made it easily capable of
swallowing a human hole number seven
Evelyn the ew1 prototype Evelyn unlike
double-oh-seven James Bond was an e-type
by a weapon the e double O one developed
similar to the earlier d types but both
were created through infecting a human
embryo with mold a fungus or fungi
organism developed by the connections
all products of this kind were
envisioned as taking the form of a
ten-year-old girl to enable them to
blend in one of the characteristics of
these bio weapons is their ability to
change their environment through the
production of excess mode which can be
vomited and form a colony and as the
mold grows this colony can grow to be up
to 40 to 50 feet in size number six the
Dell Lacko seen in Resident Evil 4 the
del Lago was a massive Plaga infected
amphibian the lift in a lake near a
Spanish village more than 66 feet long
or 20 meters in length Del Lago had an
immense jaw with several rows of teeth
and from its throat countless rooting
Plaga tentacles emerge when it swam in a
net
lack pattern capable of devouring human
beings it was a true Leviathan residing
in the lake near the villages Church it
possesses no discernible eyes but its
speed was deceptively fast even
underwater number five the mega fly seen
in Resident Evil six the mega fly was
one of many transformations of Derek C
Simmons as a result of him injecting the
C virus on himself at first a severe
infection from the potent virus made
Simmons incredibly resilient and he
survives many injuries one of his
mutations was into a t-rex looking like
creature he was able to revert back into
his human form several times and his
biggest transformation although was into
a mega fly form which unlike previous
acquired forms this form requires
assimilation of other C virus victims in
a large number and had multiple limbs
and could be way over 60 to 70 feet long
or 13 to 21 meters in overall length
number 4 the V complex the V complex of
the veronika complex was an enormous
monstrosity that was created after the
veronika plan had merged with Javier
Hidalgo it made its first appearance in
resident evil the Darkseid Chronicles
and one of its powers the V complex was
capable of reproducing asexually the
subordinate organisms produced from its
body could fly and would aggressively
defend the complex this creature was a
plan like behemoth with long stocky legs
and many spikes coming out from its body
and a bony structured head it would have
been anyway between 70 to 80 feet tall
or between 21 and 24 metres number three
the Ouroboros
aheri seen in resident evil 5 the
Ouroboros Harry is a specific
manifestation of the virally created
giant uroboros creature it is the result
of axilla jion's mutation and was
created when the Ouroboros virus
rejected her DNA mutating her body and
painfully ending her life instead of
making her a superhuman a Harry
immediately consumed the corpses within
its roots like tentacles and absorbing
their organic matter into itself and
growing to an enormous size of over 100
feet tall or 30 metres number two chaos
scene in Resident Evil 6 the hey Oz was
a massive humanoid based by organic
weapon created by the C virus it was
encountered in an underwater facility of
the Chinese coast
it's name comes from the Serbian word
for chaos and was a gargantuan creature
appearing as a centipede like cephalopod
with large and small tentacles and
lining its lower half body its origins
are unknown due to the presence of a
human-like face it was incredibly
resilient to gunfire and other injury in
general its maximum height would have
been the same as a 20-story building so
around 200 feet tall of 60 meters number
one the Malik Kota seen in Resident Evil
Revelations it is created through the
power of the T Abbas virus the hosts
were an affected form of a worm species
in the cap salad a subfamily which is an
active parasite and so live out their
whole life in the same host a fully
developed and grown malik aura appears
as a long worm covered in numerous
growths it has a circular more ring with
long thin deeds the moor is extended by
two large mandibles and that hang off
the head it is more than the length of a
cruise ship which would put it around
200 the treated meters or about 660 to
1000 feet long and so there we go the
lists of the 20 largest monsters from
Resident Evil do you like share
subscribe for other monster videos